Now that we know how failure is going to be, let's look into how to systematically find our causes.
What we need is a way to organize the debugging process
and for this, we use the process called the scientific method.
That's a cool name isn't it.
It's actually a big name for little thing but this little thing again has big consequences.
What the scientific method does is provide a systematic process
by turning some aspect of reality into a theory that explains how this aspect of reality works,
and that makes exact predictions on this reality.
Let me come up with a simple example of how the scientific methods works.
Suppose your a human--say, Isaac Newton,
your laying in your orchard and all of a sudden your watching an apple fall down.
So now you wonder, well I've just seen this apple falling. This is an aspect of reality.
Why do apples fall down?
What the scientific method does is provides you a way
to come up with the most general prediction method available.
So you can think that if an apple falls and you can repeat this experiment over and over
by letting an apple fall, you may also think about well do bricks fall.
Here's a brick and lo and behold, it falls.
Do plates fall? Oh yes they do. Do cups fall down too? Oh yes they do.
Put yourself in the mind of a 3 year old and you will find that everything falls down,
and everything really means everything.
So I can easily generalized that everything falls down.
Unless you happen to see a say--a balloon.
Here's the balloon and the lo and behold the balloon goes up.
So not everything falls down, but you can easily extend your theory
to say--well a balloon is larger than air.
If the air falls down, then the balloon must go up. So still everything falls down.
What does down actually means? Down means toward the center of the earth.
Everything is attracted towards the center of the earth.
Well, the sun is not attracted to the center of the earth. It's rather the other way around.
So you see that from these observations on even experiments that you can conduct,
you will eventually be able to come up with a full pledge theory that explains
where things will be moving, that explains at which velocity they will be moving,
which explains where the acceleration will be.
In the case of Isaac Newton, then became the theory of gravitation.